Ang kahalagahan ng quantum computing ay kapwa naiimpluwensyahan
at labis na pinalaki sa parehong oras.
Bagama't hindi nito papalitan ang mga conventional na computer
ang quantum innovation ay kumakatawan sa isang bagong paradigma ng computing.
Ang mga quantum computer ay maaaring magtulungan sa kasalukuyang computing
na imprastraktura upang malutas ang mga kumplikadong suliranin na dati ay
itinuturing na hindi praktikal o imposible.
Maaari itong magbago ng paradigm.
Halimbawa ang kahirapan ng pag-factor ng malalaking numero
sa kanilang mga pangunahing numero ang batayan ng modernong
cryptography. Para sa sukat ng mga numerong ginagamit sa modernong pampubliko
pribadong key encryption ang kalkulasyong ito ay tatagal
sa pinakamabilis na conventional na computer nang mahigit 300 trilyong taon.
Para sa isang malaking quantum computer na gumagamit
ng algorithm ni Shor ang kalkulasyong ito ay maaaring tumagal ng ilang segundo.
Ang mga kumplikadong suliranin tulad nito ay makikita sa lahat ng industriya.
Ang mga potensyal na aplikasyon ng quantum computing
ay napakarami.
Ang mga quantum computer ay lumalaki na
at nagiging mas makapangyarihan,
habang naglalayong harapin ang mas kumplikadong mga suliranin.
Mula noong 2016 ginawa ng IBM na accessible ang mga quantum computer
sa publiko sa pamamagitan ng isang website na may graphical interface na
mukhang isang musikal na nota.
at ang software development kit na Qiskit
na nagbibigay-daan sa mga gumagamit na mag-program ng mga quantum computer.
Ang mga siyentipiko sa loob at labas ng corporate world
ay nagpapatakbo ng mga eksperimento
sa pamamagitan ng mga katulad na portal. Sinisiyasat nila ang mga pamamaraan sa chemistry
at mga suliranin sa machine learning na sinusubukang malaman
kung anong uri ng mga tanong ang maaari nilang itanong
at kung paano nila babalangkasin ang mga tanong na iyon
kapag mas maayos na ang teknolohiya. Ngayon ang tamang
oras para sa mga lider ng negosyo na maghanda
para sa quantum. Handa na ang mga kondisyon para mag-eksperimento
at palawakin ang pundamental na bagong teknolohiyang ito.
Ang mga organisasyong nagnanais na maging nangunguna
sa transformational na pagbabagong ito ay
makakakuha ng competitive advantage. Ang training na ito
ay maghahanda sa iyo na simulan ang iyong quantum journey!